man mexican people work
work hard as hell man i got to be honest
with you never no complaining just
work hard dude i went to a funeral of a
mexican guy he climbed out of the casket
dug his own grave hole and then got back
in the casket man if i got to do
something for example i need to build a
picnic table or a
you know edible seating
structure
you know table and i got i got nine
people to help me do it if six out of
the nine people are mexican bro
on delay papa we getting it done i'm
telling you that dude i'm telling you
that we're gonna be eating lunch early
as a group look i saw a mexican guy cut
down a tree
make it into wood bars
bars of wood
and then use the wood to make a heat
that he built a damn tree with it
and s
inspiracional
papa